but ladies that they wrong being
promiscuous don't ever let anybody make
you feel bad about that but ladies you
guys got to own being [__] cuz
sometimes you'll [__] shame yourselves
that's not going to help the
movement like you ever have sex with a
girl you're like all right I got to go
she's like why she going to leave I feel
like a hoore it's like yeah you
are and that's okay but I don't want you
to think I'm a [__] no I
knew but there's nothing wrong with it
remember you can't tell other people not
[__] shame you do it to yourself and
then it kills me when I see women
trashing promiscuous women how about
Rachel huh what a [__] what do you mean
well she [__] a new guy every weekend
so what what do you do and every other
girl goes well I get some dinners and
drinks on them you's got to spend some
money first well wait a minute you're
calling her a [__] and you're a
prostitute isn't that way weirder she's
banging guys she likes for free you're
like how much Lobster can I get with
this
clam isn't that way horer I don't know
what do I know I'm a feminist but you
know